j'ai quasiment fini de préparer la
structure globale des épisodes sur
l'intelligence artificielle et j'ai même
commencé à écrire les premiers épisodes
et que vous allez voir va avoir des
invités assez rapidement cette série ça
commencera la semaine prochaine et d'ici
là je me suis dit que j'allais vous
laisser avec une petite vidéo qui va
être un complément à la série sur la
démocratie et qui est un extrait de
l'épisode axiome 4 où on a parlé de
démocratie avec thibaut de la chaîne me
sophie qui reformule les arguments que
j'avais abandonné contrat démocratie
d'une manière que je trouve très très
très très perspicace donc aujourd'hui je
vais pas trop bossé et je vais vous
laisser regarder cet extrait d'actium
donc quatrième vidéo on va parler d'un
youtuber que j'aime bien qui fait de
l'excès de bons trucs le grade parler de
cet argument contre la démocratie de
sign for all tu veux si tu connais c'est
que c'est sympa donc oui il va c'est une
des vidéos que j'ai plus aimé ce mois-ci
et j'avais très envie qu'on en reparle
parce qu'il ya plein de trucs chouettes
puis peut-être voir parle plus
généralement de ta série sur la
démocratie puisque finalement c'est un
petit peu c'est un petit peu le dernier
l'un des derniers épisodes avec celle
d'un mec t'as sorti sur voilà sept
poèmes sur l'ignorance
cette ode à l'ignorance et puis un
travail à voir donc d'un épisode qui pas
sortie qui justement un récapitulatif
finalement c'est un petit peu le point
d'arrivée delà de toute la série
c'est cet argument coûte la démocratie
et je trouvais ça je trouve la vidéo
vraiment super stimulant talent sont ils
sont intéressants les arguments et puis
effectivement c'est un truc
d'ailleurs tu es stressé avant de sortir
la vidéo parce que c'est vraiment c'est
pas évident de venir et de dire
ouvertement
je vais critiquer démocratie vraiment
vraiment la démocratie pad je vais pas
critiquer la démocratie telle qu'on l'a
fait en dix ans il faudrait que ce soit
plus démocratique
non je vais vraiment critiquer la
démocratie en tant que tel voilà et même
si c'était plus démocratique ce serait
pire où on a tendance aujourd'hui
associé à la démocratie une valeur en
soi ont considéré que si c'est
démocratique c'est bien c'est pas bien
parce que ça bon effet c'est bien en soi
et justement si on et utilitariste
premier point de départ c'est ça c'est
de dire si on est utile et harris déjà
ça va pas de soi il faut montrer pour
justifier que la démocratie est bien que
la démocratie a le bon effet vraiment
voilà tante a augmenté le plus grand
bonheur du plus grand monde
et une fois qu'on compose ça et bien ça
devient une question voilà à laquelle on
peut aussi bien répondre oui que non ça
dépendra des arguments qu'on trouvait et
a plutôt donné un argument en faveur du
jeu font clairement
effectivement il ya plein de raisons
pour lesquelles on peut considérer que
la démocratie n'est pas d'un point de
vue utilitariste n'est pas une imbécile
système de décision
en fait il faut bien faut se dire est
sûr c'est intéressant de regarder la
démocratie comme ça vous êtes en se
disant c'est avant tout une méthode la
démocratie un outil un outil de prise de
décision et finalement la question
compliquée qu'on a le droit de se poser
c'est est-ce que cette méthode est
efficace
est ce qu'elle se permet de prendre des
bonnes décisions et et en fait quand on
pose la question comme ça en l'examinant
d'un peu de près et sans voile à s'en
faire son oligan démocrate
c'est difficile de pas arrivés à la
conclusion que
non alors après notre question savoir
tel sa peur restait quand même la moins
pire des solutions en tout cas que
clairement il ya une bonne raison de de
dire qu' il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
problèmes inhérents à la démocratie
elle-même vraiment pas encore une fois
je pense beaucoup de gens qui voient des
trucs sur arguments contre la démocratie
vont penser à on va critiquer la façon
dont on voit là dont la démocratie
existe dans nos origines qui sont pas
vraiment des démocraties que c'était et
c'est alors que non non vraiment leaf le
il faut prendre au sérieux
ta formule lycée des arguments contre la
démocratie elle-même contre l'idée de
laisser la prise de décision au peuple
voilà un ensemble de gens pas
spécialement formés c'est les arguments
sont font très bon à la moyenne a un qui
m'a particulièrement plu
tu peux le combien tmc mais c'est celui
qui consiste à dire que finalement les
les conditions dans lesquelles la
démocratie pourrait fonctionner donc il
faudrait qu'ils aient des médias qui
informent bien pour que les citoyens
soient bien informés il faudrait que les
hommes politiques soient incités à
finalement à bien agir quand ils sont
pouvoir les incentives créé la
démocratie sont exactement contraire les
initiatives pousse plutôt à voir des
médias qui ne forme pas bien qui
polarise les opinions des gens et les
hommes politiques a finalement passé
leur temps à se critiquer mutuellement
et à déprécier le travail des autres
plutôt qu'essayer de gouverner en mieux
et soit ça tout est indécent parce que
c'est vraiment l'argument qui revient
tout le temps dit oui la démocratie ça
devrait fonctionner mais il faudrait que
les gens soient bien éduqués que c'était
et c'est dire oui mais réfléchi deux
secondes la démocratie crée un contexte
dans lequel en fait c'est tout le
contraire qui va se produire
il n'y a pas de raison de penser qu'il
en ira autrement je trouve ça un
argument qui est très puissant
ils se rendent compte que si vous voulez
que les gens soient bien éduqué je pense
qu'il n'y a pas de sujets sur lesquels
les gens sont moins bien éduqués que sur
les sujets qui touchent de près vu la
politique et c'est assez paradoxal c'est
mais il mais en fait c'est pas étonnant
c'est normal dans une démocratie les
choses sur lesquelles les gens seront
les moins bien informés
autant savoir d'informations très très
par ci a le trait voilà il n'y aurait
complètement les arguments adverses et
ses cv sur tous les sujets politiques
en tout cas c'est un argument
particulièrement fort et voyez auquel
j'avais pas spécialement pensé à voir la
vidéo sur que tu as très bien formulé
nord
merci tu arrives en vire de john brennan
c'est un livre qui m'a beaucoup inspiré
john brennan dans son livre il distingue
trois types de citoyens qu'il appelait
ce qu'il appelle les hobbits d'un côté
les hobbits c'est ce qu'ils sont ils
s'intéressent pas à la politique ils
sont très ignorants et qui se font pas
trop de partis pris politiques parce
qu'ils s'intéressent pas à la politique
et ensuite il ya les hooligans comolli
gardien de principe à lui si je crois
que c'est une brillante qui l'introduit
mais aussi je l'utilisé c'est parce que
brennan de l'utiliser les hooligans gens
réfugiés fait parler de vidéo est là
dessus c'est des gens qui ont un parti
pris mais très pays et qui sont victimes
du biais de conforama de confirmation et
qui vont défendre leurs valeurs sont
irrationnels et enfin il ya les vulcains
qui viennent sous les gens qui sont
capables de penser rationnellement
d'être qui sont parfaitement informés
qu'ils sont capables de tout bien faire
et ce que dit brennan c'est que tous les
modèles classiques démocratie suppose
que les citoyens sont des vulcains tu as
peuvent devenir des vulcains l'écrit
bonnes conditions sauf qu'en pratique
notamment à cause des 610 les gens sont
soit au bit soit hooligans mais j'avais
lu un petit article où il expliquait
qu'en gros on à l'optimisme
un peu des lumières c'était de se dire
le peuple aujourd'hui hobbit
mais voilà on mettait dans une
démocratie et ça deviendra un peuple de
vulcain si tu sors les hobbits de chez
eux ils vont devenir des vulcains en
fait non les hobbies en france plutôt
que de venir des hooligans
effectivement c'était pas un truc
évident je peux comprendre que
on pensait que sa lettre voilà
formidable mais en fait aujourd'hui on a
quand même pas mal de données des
sciences sociales qui nous montrent que
dans une délibération sur un sujet
politique les gens se comporte pas en
vue de 15 se comporte clairement ce
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens a dû en avoir
dans les commentaires de gens qui vont
me dire oui mais alors il faudrait une
démocratie délibérative au genre de
choses est typiquement en tout cas ça
c'est beau cette idée de démocratie
délibérative
mais le problème c'est que franchement
ça ça ignore vraiment pas mal de données
des sciences sociales qui tente à dire
que dans une délibération famille d une
démocratie délibérative c'est que vous
vous réunissez les gens dans une salle
et ils délibèrent ils discutent entre
eux et à la fin il ya un consensus qui
ne sera bien en avoir à mettre tout le
monde d'accord mais c'est pas comme ça
que ça se passe
on le sait on sait que ça ne se passe
pas comme ça que tu mets des gens qui ne
sont a priori pas tout à fait d'accord
entre eux dans une même salle
ils vont ressortir à couteaux tirés et
encore plus tôt la risée qu'avant enfin
si tu soutient le contraire et c'est
finalement ce que soutiennent les gens
qui ne défendent la démocratie
délibérative
c'est plus ou moins obligés de défendre
le contraire eh ben c'est pas très
solide
expérimentalement carla plutôt des
impressions des données en sciences
sociales qui nous montrent le contraire
et puis le il ya pas mal de recherches
là dessus des choses avec son trait dans
l'inquiétant sur fait que s'il y a des
des groupes identifiés pardon par sexe
ou par par couleur de peau souvent le
débat va les délibérations va amener ces
clans s'opposent et que ça va renforcer
encore plus le ligue à nice mais
et ça m'a empêché donc les gens non pas
tant parce qu'il y avait des espoirs des
philosophes des lumières ou autres qui
espéraient que justement havas avec des
systèmes délibératif les gens seraient
plus concernés par les difficultés des
autres mais en fait ce que montrent les
expériences c'est pas que les
expériences et aussi les études des
jurys délibératif aux états unis des
trucs plus empirique qui se rapproche
d'hivers plus de la délibération qui
sera imaginée par les ceux qui pensent à
la démocratie délibérative
bah finalement à ça cette rencontre de
deux côtés opposés en fait exacerbé les
différences et finalement une des
meilleures façons de réduire le racisme
c'est de ne pas en parler que du cas des
expériences qui montrent que bah c'est
ici on dit aux gens ou les associe par
nom ou par par par d'autres trek sont
pas la couleur de peau
les différences raciales vont
disparaître que l'on pût faire attention
à ça alors que si on voit on suggère un
petit peu il ya le mot couleur de peau
qui qui qui sortent tout de suite les
gens vont s'identifier par la couleur de
peau et ça va exacerber en fait le lit
ganis
en tout cas le problème heures à sirugue
ouais c'est assez déprimant mais c'est
typiquement le genre de truc assez
déprimante il faut tenir compte quand on
pense à voile à l'organisation la prise
de décision donc assez souvent c'est un
peu l'idée derrière le concept de
vulcain c'est que effectivement les les
théories
les théories politiques ont tendance à a
pas assez tenir compte de ce qu'on sait
du comportement des gens réels sans
imaginer des de comportement idéal il
faudrait que les gens se comporte comme
ça dure d'accord il faudrait mais de
fait si c'est pas le cas
bah c'est qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'on fait
ça c'est vrai même au niveau de la
recherche entre certains chercheurs qui
ont des points de vue opposés sur
certaines questions parfois il ya des
clashs énorme et mais qui arrive pas se
mettre d'accord délibération empire les
aggrave le problème
ces deux fonds ça pose problème car en
tout cas notamment parce que tu étais
assez critique envers les hobbits chu
s'est froissé pas dans la vidéo c'est
donc plutôt dans la com en terre tout à
fait là dans la vidéo sur alors que je
sais pas c'était ce que brennan est
vraiment très critique envers les gens
vont dire les obus dont certaines
mesures ça pourrait rejoindre le 7ème
critique que tu fais quand la démocratie
qu'on c'est à dire c'est très coûteux en
temps et quelque part il faudrait
arrêter de voir dans le fait de
s'intéresser aux problèmes politiques
une sorte de devoir moral bien quelque
part j'ai envie de dire les hobbits ceux
qui ont reconnu le fait que bah écoute
c'est très coûteux s'intéresse à tout ça
moi j'ai pas spécialement envie j'ai
autre chose à faire je préfère faire des
maths et et voyager et j'en sais rien
voilà et ne pas ne pas embêter les gens
avec mes opinions politiques
et c'est passé pas une position j'ai à
dire que je sais c'est mal d'être
arbitre français ça fait partie des de
construction sociale c'est ce genre
d'idées très démocratique justement
de culpabiliser les hobbits qui vous
sert comme un hobbit vous voir je vous
dis qu'il faudrait que je sois plus
hobbit
ben ouais je comprends les yeux mais
personnellement aussi j'ai du temps ça
il ya des périodes en france où c'est
absolument impossible de ne pas avoir
d'opinion politique vous vois tu étais
obligé de d'être pour ou contre intel
c'est terrible quand on a connu un
mobile au fond de soi mais quelque part
c'est vrai que c'est pas un sujet qui
m'intéresse plus que moi j'aime bien
parler d'économie ou ce genre de choses
mais c'est la politique s'est
fondamentalement inintéressant parce que
c'est beaucoup une affaire de personnes
et j'en sais rien moi aussi j'aime tel
ou tel un meeting j'en sais rien je les
connais pas je sais pas ce qui est c'est
très coûteux en temps d'abord de se
faire une opinion de ces choses là est
effectivement fond ce faux pas en
vouloir au but mais l'impression qu'il
faudrait plutôt là à leur dire voilà
vous avez déjà très intéressant voyez
quelque chose appelée dépréciative dans
ce côté hobbit
je sais pas c'est pas pour moi les gens
sont des hobbits sur plein de sujets
presque tout le monde son sens des
hobbits sur la philosophie sur les mâts
tous ces trucs là au sens ne sont pas
sortis de chez eux voir qu'est-ce que
quelle vaste monde qui les entoure juste
on seul truc qu'on n'a pas le droit
d'être un hobbit c'est en politique lors
l'objet de sortir et je pense est une
des raisons pour lesquelles on a le
sentiment qu'ils qu'on n'a pas le droit
d'être un hobbit en politique c'est que
on a le sentiment qu'on oued d'être tous
plus ou moins expert en fait politique
c'est ça qui avait classé frappant ouais
en politique très ignorants de l'étendue
de notre ignorance en politique pour
coup et ça c'est clair mais y'a une
vidéo était fois que c'est peut-être
dans celle-ci d'air là où tu explique
pourquoi est ce que fait non c'est très
valorisé le fait d'avoir des opinions
d'avoir des convictions des défend et
c'est un truc qui très valorisé surtout
des convictions politiques
ta conviction intuition liste je pense
qu'on s'en fiche complète à convictions
politiques c'est un truc qui va être
très valorisé l'idée que tu en es et que
tu les défendre un petit peu alors moi
qui les défendent à la façon dont on se
bat avec l'idée de détruire les
arguments adverses pas du tout en tenir
compte
alors quand tu défends un camp politique
reconnaître l'intérêt et la pertinence
un argument qui va pas dans son sens
lestrem intéressé au mieux des mauvais
arguments en sa faveur en faveur de ton
clan que des bunds arrivant dans le
connaît c'est triste parce que je veux
dire si on voulait vraiment si on avait
une attitude un peu plus de vulcain
quelque part justement vis-à-vis de tout
ça on se formeraient voilà en tenant
compte des arguments qui vont nous
entendre sur cnn dans l'autre c'est
clairement pas de cette façon là dont on
s'attend mais quand on valorise même la
façon de s'informer le sentiment donc
dans son livre brennan il parle pas mal
lu deux drulingen comme étant celui qui
est incapable de défendre le côté opposé
et ce qui sous-entend qu'est ce qui ce
qui suggère c'est que vulcain en tout
cas quelqu'un de plus âgé
politiquement c'est quelqu'un qui
devrait être capable de padt ample dire
c'est de se faire passer pour un mec du
camp opposé
et de sortir un speech qui défend un
côté opposé encore mieux au moins aussi
bien que la plupart des gens du côté
opposé jeu se débat avec karim piriou de
politiken où il demandait si du coup ce
que je pensais que un noir américain à
l'époque de l'esclavagé devait être en
mesure vers un devoir moral de d'être
capable de défendre l'esclavagisme
pourquoi ce serait un devoir d'être un
vulcain je pensais pas nécessairement le
cas je peux comprendre pourquoi t'as pas
envie de défendre l'esclavagisme quand
tu subis c'est certain mais après est ce
que pour prendre une décision de façon à
former
je pense à ça reste quand même un
critère qui est assez valable cette idée
d'être capable de de comprendre les
arguments de cinq sens aussi bien que
dans l'autre effectivement je pense que
c'est même utile que peut-être que je
suis un petit peu mais enfin si tu veux
rejetée parce que dépend d'une position
c'est je pousse à toujours plus élégant
de commencé par défendre de la position
opposée et d'être très convaincant dans
cela et puis de dit ensuite montré où
sont les failles et puis ensuite sortir
des arguments
je trouve ça je vois que c'est très
utile de comprendre le compte ou le camp
opposé que même pour des raisons de
bonnes délibération pourquoi est ce que
les gens ont l'impression que les hommes
politiques sont tous incompétents c'est
parce que tous les hommes politiques
disent que tout le monde et d'europe et
ans au feu
en gros et le truc c'est que c'est
normal qu'ils janvier à cette idée qui
et les incentives d'une démocratie en
fait sont incompatibles avec le bon
fonctionnement de bureaucratie c'est que
c'est normal en tant qu'homme politique
un homme politique qui vont c'est à dire
oui alors vraiment il ya des bonnes
idées là bas à gauche est une bonne idée
voilà dans le camp opposé il se fait
démolir c'est évident donc il peut passe
voilà il se fera pas élire il se fera
démolir par sa part c'est par ses
congénères et
dont on n'a pas le droit donc vraiment
tout le monde va toujours dire que les
arguments des autres que ce que font les
autres c'est le pire qu'on pouvait faire
et c est ça donne effectivement cette
impression du coup que tout le monde est
incompétent et que personne ne sait ce
qu'il fait est que voilà et c'est
malheureux parce qu'en fait il y aurait
moyen de discuter rationnellement de ce
que font les hommes politiques
en réalité mais juste effectivement pas
dans une démocratie c'est ça qui est
assez frappant c'est que on ne peut pas
discuter rationnellement des malades et
des mesures que prennent les hommes
politiques dans une démocratie très
clairement en tout cas en train de
politique qui voilà qui cherche à être
élu et cetera c'est juste impossible et
7 et du coup ça déteint sur les
individus aussi cas c'est sûr que
l'indignation est une stratégie optimale
pour les politiciens
il faut toujours donner l'impression que
ce que font tous les autres c'est
absolument aller vers des choses à faire
est que quelques pays sur le bord de
l'effondrement sauf si ils arrivent à se
faire élire on ne peut pas prévoir un
autre initiative que ça à dire que si
tout à coup tu quelqu'un décide d'avoir
un autre discours il serait inaudible
oui ce wigan y voit les gagnerait pas
donc
même chose pour les médias effectivement
elle est mais il faut donner à lire ce
que les gens ont envie de dire un
lecteur un lecteur de l'humanité sait
très bien ce qu'il va lire dans
l'humanité comme un lecteur du figaro
c'est très bien ce qui va le dire en
filière s est avoué que on a on a des
biais de confirmation de deux dirigeants
machette au pire forcément ça c'est ce
vers de ses dires du journal des
journaux de son opinion et donc n'être
exposées calme une argumentation qui va
dans le sens de mon opinion du coup mais
est ce qu est ce que j'aurai envie de
poser la question est ce que tu as des
arguments pourraient démocratie sinon
pour la démocratie c'est un talent un
peu parlé en fait mine de rien
l'argument principal que je vois pour la
démocratie c'est c'est que c'est ça
permet de valoriser le capital moral ça
permet de fédérer tout plein de gens
ensemble et de nous de les aider à
coopérer sur des valeurs communes que
c'est pas directement lié à la politique
ça entretient un sentiment de déjà un
sentiment d'unité et d'unité nationale
en même temps je ne sais pas parce que
au lendemain d'une élection il ya 50% de
déçus 70% mais je pense quand même que
ça reste la démocratie voilà on a tous
participé ensemble à l'élection
c'est là que les drapeaux nationaux sont
plus sortis sentiment d'appartenance un
peu plus fort à ce moment là c'est à la
coupe du monde c'est bien mieux
clairement ouais mais c'est tous les
quatre ans elle a préféré un truc en
plus by vaut une coupe du monde un peu l
affaire tous les ans il faut que la
france se soit forte la tunisie fait
vraiment ça le but honnêtement le foot
est bien plus utile de ce point de vue
là que que l'élection que n'importe
quelle élection a clairement agi en
pensant que ça mais plutôt et c'était
peut-être pas évident que ça finirait
comme ça mais que ça tend de plus en
plus à mettre en avant les autres les
dissensions dans la société
je dis pas que c'est pas un bon argument
je pense effectivement il ya de ça quand
même
c'étaient d'autres c'était un argument
toit pour la démocratie
un bon argument c'est quand même de dire
que c'est pas si évident de trouver des
systèmes
alternatif qui soit satisfaisant les
pistes grassi
voilà une idée intéressante mais tu vois
bien pourquoi est ce que les pistes au
cra ci aurait un problème en légitimité
en fait même temps l'idée de légitimité
serment quelque chose qui relève de
l'éducation c'est à dire que juste on
n'est pas et c'est ça fait partie de
l'éducation démocratique finalement de
dire que sur certains sujets en tout cas
il n'y a pas d' expertise qui compte et
c'est un problème parce que du coup
c'est ça qui empêcherait les systèmes
que lepisto cratie me pister mocratie je
puisse vous dire de fonctionner si
effectivement on n'est pas prêt à renier
notre notre argument importante pour la
démocratie qui est que face à un peu
l'égalitarisme c'est à dire qu'il ya ya
ya pas deux et pas de classe sociale
n'est pas de passer un peu les arguments
anti piste au crac visuel on dire que
quoi qu'il ya des gens qui sont experts
elles sont au dessus des autres
créer un sentiment de supériorité je
pense qu'il ya pas mal de gens qui sont
sensibles à ça fait que grâce à la
démocratie on est tous égaux d'une
certaine manière ce qui est pas
forcément vrai d'ailleurs mais n'est
plus plus égaux que que ouais ce qu'on
pourrait répondre en temps si on les
défend dépister mocratie serait que les
positions d'experts sont ouvertes à tous
que c'est une comment ça les gens sont
égaux les gens sont égaux sens il
appartient qu à toi de faire des études
en sciences politiques ou en économie ce
que tu veux et ne prendre pas la
délibération ouais enfin après tu vas
dire bah il y en a qui sont plus aisé
que d'autres pour réussir à ça après
donc redit je sais pas s'il prend cette
comparaison là j'ai écouté un podcast à
une dizaine grenier quelque temps je
sais qu'il ait pris cette idée là qui
était assez marrante d'une comparaison
avec le permis de conduire typiquement
on donne pas permis à n'importe qui
voilà même au nom de l'égalité on se
rend bien compte que c'est dangereux de
donner le permis à n'importe qui donc
ont fait passer un permis est au
demeurant c'est à ces inégalités à la
façon dont on le fait parce que ça coûte
très très cher de le passer et la voir
et quand même un gros avantage dans la
vie ceci dit on est prêt à on s'offusque
pas de voix de l'organisation de tout ça
l'étude tudyk et pourquoi est ce qu'on
ne fait pas ce que quelqu'un qui conduit
mal au volant d'une voiture c'est très
dangereux pour des individus
il est sain que tu pourrais faire un
parallèle avec avec la démocratie des
électeurs qui conduisent mal d'électeurs
qui votent mal c'est très dangereux
aussi pour une société
et pourtant le permis de voter dans le
donne à tout le monde et tu dis on va ça
c'est un peu similaire va maintenant de
la même façon qu'il ya un permis de
conduire
vous avez tous le droit de conduire mais
vous n'avez pas tous le permis de
conduire de tous le droit d'apprendre à
conduire mais elle voit la belle vous
avez tous le droit de voter juste il
faut passer 1 termine pas faire trop de
bêtises c'est chaud c'est une
argumentation qui est assez solide et
qui pourrait même légitimer le fait que
effectivement il n'a tout qui savent
plus facile de l'avoir que d'autres et
très clairement le permis de conduire
c'est le cas il ya des gens pour qu'ils
savaient plus difficile de la voir parce
que ça coûte super cher et voilà si tu
peux faire conduite accompagnée avec tes
parents voilà seize ans c'est plus
facile que 6 à 18 ans tu ne commences à
te payer tout seul je pense à plus
d'impact sur la vie d'un individu
d'avoir mon permis de conduire que
d'avoir non pas remis de voter après
aussi si j'essaie de faire mon
pro-démocrates ce que ce que ce que je
dirais c'est que il ya quand même le
fait d'avoir un permis de conduire et
pas forcément valorisé socialement ni
pas un mec est trop fort et
l'intervention dure alors que si c'était
un permis de voter ça serait
cabu aujourd'hui par plupart des gens
comme étant une distinction sociale
importante ouais
brennan donne aussi l'exemple du
plombier disent en choeur plombier
aujourd'hui c'est quelqu'un qui a une
expertise en plus c'est un expert et
parfums bizarrement c'est pas une
expertise qui valorisait alors que
médecin sait c'est valoriser médecin
c'est pareil c'est quelqu'un qui a un
pouvoir de vie ou de mort sur ses
patients quelqu'un qui a beaucoup de
pouvoir plombier bon je sais pas si la
prod vie je me suis noir sur ses pieds
peut te sauver la vie dans certaines
situations peu expertise différent tu
peux te donner la vie et ses deux
expériences différentes par contre sont
valorisé socialement des façons très
différentes ce qui est dit brian c'est
qu'il faut pas voir le doute permis de
voter comme comme le médecin je veux
dire comme quelqu'un qui a vraiment un
pouvoir très supérieurs et je pense que
justement voilà à ce moment là faire pas
mal la valorisation des hobbits pour le
coup c'est à dire que bon voilà c'est
une expertise et puis si vous l'avez pas
c'est pas grave du tout que vous peut
être
s'intéresser à plein d'autres choses
très très très ennuyeux c'est noté je
pas si je le passerai sais pas si on me
profonde il fallait connaître les
instituts c'est un bon argument ne
maîtrise pas quelqu'un parce qu'il n'a
pas le permis de conduire
par contre on pourrait effectivement
éventuellement s'exposer au mépris
nouveauté mais si une affaire
d'éducation est ce qu ont valorisé
socialement justement la démocratie nous
a mis dans la tête que c'etait tres
partie de la dignité d'un être humain ou
d'un groupe d'avoir j'espère que vous
avez aimé ce petit extrait des podcasts
axiome si vous avez aimé bah allez voir
la chaîne axiome ou le podcast action
puisque axiom est aussi disponible sur
itunes et sur android au format mp3
notamment le cinquième épisode devrait
bientôt sortir
riez pas encore été tourné mais je pense
qu'il va être vraiment bien beaucoup de
choses intéressantes à dire sur le
prochain élection le puis tant qu'à
faire si vous n'êtes pas encore abonné
monsieur fiba allez-y ce qui l'est c'est
juste génial et c'est extrêmement lié à
beaucoup de choses dont on a parlé sur
ce forum et moi je vous dis à la semaine
prochaine pour parler d'intelligence
artificielle